[Music]  merry christmas clara  godfather your gift this year  will be something you'll never forget  most people don't realize there are  troubled realms  within our world  [Music]  and you hold the key  to their secrets  remember clara nothing is as it seems  where am i you're in the four realms  princess clara  princess at your service your majesty  maybe i have been spending too much time  in the attic  welcome to our world the land of  snowflakes  the land of flowers and the land of  sweets  but the fourth realm this is where our  troubles began  mother ginger started this war don't you  know it's dangerous here  i hope you'll be the one to finish it  it's time to save the kingdom  it's just the laws of physics do those  laws always work  ready  she's gathering her forces you're the  only one who can stop her  i've been expecting you  it's time  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you